the goosebumps and the chills that we
get from music it comes from sad music
it doesn't come from the happy and
upbeat tunes it's like there's something
that that music is conveying to us about
the nature of reality that makes us feel
kind of electric and alive because it's
speaking some deep truth
i watched your very famous ted talk
a few years ago and in it you hoped that
the world was going to become a more
introvert friendly place
uh doing uh a sort of analysis of what's
happened over the last few years how do
you feel that's gone what's the
post-mortem
i think it's gone amazingly well and
also that we still have a long way to go
and i think you know that's true of any
social shift
you can
sometimes see changes but still know
that there's still a distance to travel
but yeah when i compare things to the
way they were 10 years ago i think
it's been a pretty seismic shift just in
terms of the
the degree to which people are aware of
the fact that we are introverts or
extroverts or maybe somewhere in between
and that that shapes so much of who we
are
and uh and the willingness of companies
and schools and organizations to talk
about it
um but i would say most of all the
biggest shift i've seen is
in individual humans you know all the
letters that i get from people telling
me that they once had felt like they
didn't have permission to be their true
selves
and that now they do and they embrace it
and
there's this amazing paradox at the
heart of so many of these letters which
is that
the more people
embrace their true quiet nature the more
successful they become in the outer
facing world i see this over and over
again
it's very difficult to compete with
somebody that's being themselves right
no one can beat you
exactly exactly
and um
and i think humans really like truth
uh most of all
and
when you feel like somebody is
telling the truth about who they are and
living that truth we like it you know
and we want to be with them yeah i did a
tedx talk um the start of last year and
this was the entire topic of it it was
about embracing your weirdness and about
the fact that dali was this salvador
dali was this unbelievably unique human
uh but if he hadn't embraced everything
that he was we weren't going to get
darley out of da vinci and we weren't
going to get dolly out of michelangelo
it was important for him to embrace all
of the elements of him the ones that got
him locked in a deep-sea diving suit
that he had to be wrenched out of in the
middle of a talk and the one where he
was throwing himself down the stairs at
nine years old because he just liked
pain like you know he was a
bizarre guy
beyond the facial hair and
yeah
it's it's very very right there is a
resonance that you get when you can see
somebody just being themselves and just
being truthful and um it's very alluring
which is bizarre because a lot of the
time especially with introverts that's
exactly not what they want
they want like the allure to kind of
come and go as they please and some of
the people that are the most engaging
are the ones who are
um not necessarily looking for it
yeah i mean
i don't know i i i do think introverts
want to be able to
yeah they may just not always want to
talk about who they are i think they
want different ways of expressing it or
to be able to just take time off i think
that's the thing
it's a
in a twi in a 24 7 on society they want
time off i agree uh how do you go from
talking about introverts to thinking
about feelings of sorrow and longing
then
well it's very interesting in that i
thought that
talking about sorrow and longing in this
book bittersweet i i thought when i
started this project that it was a
pretty big departure from what i had
done in the past you know just like a
completely new topic and it is but
what i'm finding is that so much of the
way people are reacting to it is
it's very similar to what i heard with
quiet in that
so many people saying oh yeah you know
this is who i really am
this is speaking to a deep truth about
myself or about the way i perceive the
world but not one i had put into words
before or not one that i felt like i
could put into words before because
you're supposed to be so upbeat and so
positive you're not supposed to talk
about these kinds of things um so in
that way there there was this uh this
real parallel that i had completely not
been aware of when i first started what
are the emotions that you're talking
about in bittersweet
um well i am talking about sorrow and
longing i'm talking about
i'm really talking about his joy and
sorrow though like i'm talking about the
way in which
the nature of reality is that joy and
sorrow are forever paired and light and
dark are forever paired
and and so we have to embrace both of
them and accept both of them and look at
both of them in a clear-eyed kind of way
and to understand that
everyone and everything that we love
most is impermanent not going to live
forever but that there's something about
really living deeply in that perception
in that apprehension
that is a kind of gateway to creativity
to connection to transcendence and you
can feel this you know when i mean what
what got me down this whole garden path
in the first place is um
is just my lifelong love of sad music
and what sad music unleashes in us i
mean certainly in me but but then i
start then i started to realize like
they're all these studies that find
um
you know the goosebumps and the chills
that we get from music it comes from sad
music it doesn't come from the happy and
upbeat tunes it's like there's something
that that music is conveying to us about
the nature
of reality that makes us feel kind of
electric and alive because it's speaking
some deep truth
what do you think is going on there how
is it that music can evoke an emotional
response in that sort of way
um
i think that the musician is saying to
us in a pre-verbal way or in a you know
super verbal way maybe
[Music]
they're saying to us everything that
you've ever felt and maybe not wanted to
say
i'm telling you i've felt it too i'm
telling you everyone's felt it too and
i'm gonna take the further step of
turning this thing that you felt into
something
unbelievably beautiful
um so there's a kind of
yeah there's a transformation in it and
a kind of union in it
it is interesting to think about the
sort of impact that that music has on us
i i wonder i would love to speak to a an
evolutionary psychologist about it and
think about how how is this adaptive you
know how is it that music can cause us
to it can induce this emotional state is
that a byproduct of something else you
know is it that there is something else
that we need to be attuned to and it
happens to be that music can tap into
that as well or is there a specific
pathway that's causing us to be able to
be made
crying weeping messes on the floor
by the right song at the right time i
know it's a very interesting question
and psychologists and neuroscience have
looked at what it is about sad music
that induces all these feelings of you
know pleasure is to like simple a word
for it but all these great feelings in
us and i i don't know that anyone's ever
come up with a really great explanation
for it um you know they talk about
how it
brings our bodies to a state of physical
equilibrium
um but
but what i found more
although it was my kind of bias going
into this whole question to be looking
at things more from a scientific and
evolutionary point of view and and i do
that in certain ways that we can talk
about um
the question about music specifically
i ended up finding
it was more interesting to think about
it in religious terms than anything else
which i hadn't expected because i didn't
really go in as a religious person like
i think of myself as an agnostic and i
still am
but um
but i think that what
when you listen to music what you start
to realize is that like a huge majority
of the songs that touch us the most are
tuning into a sense of longing like an
existential yearning for something
that's what the music is expressing and
so it's this it's expressing the exact
same thing
that religion expresses in its longing
for
the garden of eden and its longing for
zion and its longing for mecca and its
longing for the beloved of the soul
that's one of the deepest aspects of
human dna and for those of us who aren't
used to thinking in religious terms
we're kind of
cut off from that
we're cut off from that side of our
nature
but that's what music is doing
um
when you listen to it you can hear it
and then and and there are other
manifestations of that that we have in
our art like
you know dorothy is longing for
somewhere over the rainbow um odysseus
in in the odyssey he's longing for
for home he's longing for ithaca and
that's what sets him off on his
adventure
so
you see this like embedded into our
deepest works of art
and i think we're not um in conscious
enough relationship
to
that longing even though
it's uh
even though it taps our deepest nature
how is joy and sorrow different from
something like ore and dread
uh
well
i think of ah and dread as being very
different and i know people talk about
oz being
somehow in relation to fear which i i
don't fully buy so i'm going to separate
those out i i will say that um
we have in the quiz
in the book a bittersweet quiz that i
developed with
the psychologists david yaden at johns
hopkins and scott barry kaufman
and and it's also on the website for
people who want to just kind of take it
quickly it's uh susan kane.net if you
want to just do it in a minute or two
but
we did preliminary studies with the quiz
the quiz basically measures how prone
you are to this
experience of bitter sweetness this kind
of like intense awareness of joy and
sorrow
and what we found is that people who are
high
in their proneness to these states you
know they they spend a lot of time that
bittersweet state of being
they also are prone to states of awe
and wonder and spirituality so there
seems to be some kind of connection
there
um i don't know that we know exactly
what it is but i will say that there's
also a high correlation
between bittersweetness and what the
psychologist elaine aaron calls high
sensitivity
which is a kind of like
it describes 15 to 20 of people who are
just intensely reactive to
everything about life you know the good
and the bad you feel it all very deeply
um so there's something about feeling it
all the joy and the sorrow and
therefore being able to take in um
states that put us into that place of
awe
do you find when you've been speaking to
people about this that some people kind
of just don't get what you're talking
about i'm thinking about some of the
friends that i know my history
is as a club promoter so stood on the
front door of nightclubs and i can think
about a big group of people a bunch of
them are athletes as well where if i
started talking to them about this sort
of gorgeous feeling of of bleak
melancholy um that i had when i was
going through the um
hills of iceland on a bus for instance
and it's just endless endless landscapes
of rocks moss covered rocks nothing
nothing living there
that i can see
and the fact that whenever there's a
planet earth documentary
that gets released immediately i always
go to the most bleak landscape i always
want the snow or the ice one i want the
antarctica one and there's something
about that that i find sort of
beautiful and terrifying at the same
time and
i know that as i was as i say that to
some of my friends they're just gonna
look at me and go yeah but why yeah that
sounds like it sucks and
have you found this have you found that
there are some people that kind of just
don't seem to get it or at least don't
feel it definitely definitely yeah and
i've had um some funny interviews
a couple with friends of mine where they
would say you know i just took your
bittersweet quiz and i scored a zero
like on every single one of the
questions zero zero zero so yeah there
definitely are some people like that um
and
i i i do
this is what i think i think there are
some people who come into this world
with a temperament like of high
sensitivity that sort of predisposes
them to
getting into the state
um i think there's some people who come
to it via life experience you know maybe
they've
experienced enough of life's mix of
trials and triumphs that they get to
this date and some people really don't
um
and the way i think of it all is that
if you think of the lesson of all
the myths and the fairy tales and the
marvel movies and all of it you know
it's basically telling us there's a
whole array of different superpowers on
offer right there's like lightsabers
there's wizard hats there's um
you know some people can climb up
buildings and stick to the walls and
it's really easy for them and and i just
think of this as one
kind of power
with which to relate
to other people
and to the world um and it doesn't have
to be for everyone
it's strange thinking about the uh
double-sided nature of a lot of the
things that we not necessarily might not
like about ourselves but sometimes
are uh not super proud of it right it's
very easy to wear uh the badge on your
sleeve of being a super outgoing
charismatic um
uh extroverted person or the sort of
person who can watch a scary movie and
not get scared or watch a sad movie and
not get sad
there is kind of something
sort of cool and stoic and heroic about
that that's
not me in the slightest
and
it does seem a little bit like
on the face of it you could perhaps take
those
those
insights that you get about the world
and see them as a weakness
and yet
when you look at them very very closely
you realize that they're probably just
the other side of something that you
really care about yeah they're the
opposite side of the coin that gives you
the insights that you genuinely love
discovering about the world or it's your
curiosity or it's your desire for
adventure it's your desire to connect
with people whatever it might be and the
price that you pay for having the thing
that you care about the most is one of
the things that sometimes you can be a
little bit embarrassed about in private
and um yeah you don't get to sort of
pick
different characteristics like clothes
off a shelf you just sort of put your
entire personality on as a onesie and
then slowly slowly over time start to
curate it towards something that's
closer to what you would like to have
yeah or or
i i was with you until the very last bit
about curated
to something you would like to have i'm
not sure
how much of a choice we get i think it's
more a question of
using
the the temperament and the personality
and the life experiences and all of it
you know
using it in your
best and deepest way um but yeah i i
really agree with what you just said
um
oh shoot i was just gonna add something
to that
and then oh yeah i know um
with the bittersweet quiz what we also
found to your point is that there is a
a mild correlation between
bittersweet types
and pronus to anxiety and depression
and that really doesn't surprise me at
all i think these two things go together
you know i i think
you could probably envision it as a
spectrum and somebody who
is kind of right here in the middle of
a bitter sweetness they might edge a
little farther out along that spectrum
and it might tip over into something
very difficult you know of severe
anxiety or depression because
these things are related
excuse me
so
so yeah
if you're the person with that
temperament it's a question of well how
do you live in a state of what i think
of as a happy melancholy as opposed to
a disabling depression
those might be cousins but they're
completely different life experiences
does sorrow and longing come about from
pain in your experience
i think they're related to each other um
sure i mean you have
i guess it could be physical pain but
certainly emotional pain i mean you have
maybe that's the definition of sorrow
that you're experiencing a kind of
emotional pain
i think longing is a slightly different
state
because longing has more of a sweetness
in it you know it's more of like
an orientation towards that which you
would want to have that you may not have
right now but but there's something
about the orientation in that direction
that brings you closer um
to
the thing that you think is most perfect
or beautiful or good or true
um
so
yeah so longing
in our culture the word longing
sounds like it's very
like you might be mired in longing you
know it sounds like it's something very
negative
but
literally the word the etymology of the
word longing it literally means like to
grow longer and to reach for something
so i think of that as a quite
positive state of being how can this be
transformed into something more like
creativity or love got somebody that's
listening now and thinking yep me that's
me love antarctica when it comes on
planet earth and bleak landscapes and
sad music
how can they transmute that into
something more useful
yeah well
so for when it comes to create that
there's a lot of answers to that on the
creativity side of the question
um
when you look at what many creative
artists are doing what they're really
doing is they're taking
pain and turning it into something
beautiful
so it's a kind of transforming process
um so i i say to people you know
whatever pain you fi you feel you can't
get rid of
make that your creative offering like
that that is your wellspring
um
that's so much of what people go to art
looking for you know they're they're
looking for
someone to express for them
in some kind of like
beautiful or otherwise transcendent form
um
[Music]
to express for them something they felt
that they can't really talk about at the
grocery store or you know like
chatting with their colleague at work
it's just
not right to talk about it there but
but art is going to do it for you
so
it's the source of our great creative
impulses it's not
it's not an accident that there's study
after study that i talk about in the
book finding that so many of our great
artists um have been orphaned uh
when they were children
um there was one study
that that took a bunch of unsuspecting
people and had them give speeches to
an audience of of
people who the researchers had planted
there and half of the audiences
um
smiled upon the people as they gave
their talks and applauded very
enthusiastically and then the other half
looked very disapproving
and so the people who gave the
talks to the disapproving audiences were
pretty bummed afterwards
well they all had to do collages when
they were done
and it turned out that the
the collages done by the people who are
in a bad mood because they had given the
the talks to the unhappy audiences um
those people
made collages that were rated much
higher for creativity by a panel of
artists than the others did and that
that was especially true that effect was
especially pronounced for people who had
a hormonal profile going in that
suggested emotional vulnerability
so there's something about
tuning in to
what we can call your antarctica state
that is connected with a creative
impulse and it's not to say i really
want to say this
again i'm not advocating for depression
in fact i think it's really difficult to
be
creative when you're depressed if not
impossible
it's more about just tapping into
some sort of state of imperfection and
doing everything you can
to transform it in the direction of
perfection that's like the great human
undertaking
what about love
love um
so with love
part of the lesson here
there's a reason in the book i i i tell
at some length the story of the bridges
of madison county
um which was this
blockbuster book and movie about this um
about a a woman
kind of trapped in a pretty mediocre
marriage let's say um in a midwestern
farm town and one day her family goes
away for a week
and
there knocks on the door um this
handsome photographer from national
geographic magazine
and they fall into a passionate four-day
affair
and
he tries to convince her
to leave her family and go off with him
and at first she's actually packing her
bags ready to do that
until she decides to unpack them
and she unpacks her bags partly because
she doesn't want to you know she doesn't
want to abandon her family
but
it's also deeper than that
it's because she understands that
they
she and this photographer have already
together
kind of gone to eden
and that even if they were just
going to stay together they wouldn't get
to stay there
and you start to realize that this is a
story not really about
marriage and adultery and that kind of
thing it's it's really a story about
longing itself and that that's what the
photographer represented
and
in our own love lives
i think it's incredibly helpful to
understand this about ourselves
that
that we have this kind of emotional
makeup as humans because otherwise what
you end up doing is you know you enter a
new love affair
and basically you and your partner take
each other to
eden for some period of time
and then eventually then you don't get
to stay there because you find out that
they're imperfect and you remember that
you're imperfect and
and yeah
and
and if you don't understand this whole
dynamic you might feel like okay that's
a sign that that relationship was all
wrong and now i've got to go to the next
person who might be able to bring me to
eden and then we can stay there for good
but if you understand this dynamic about
human nature i think you approach your
relationships with much more forgiveness
and your own self with much more
forgiveness
and you can experience love in its human
forms and appreciate the moments of eden
when they come and appreciate
imperfect love
the rest of the time
and
and really derive the benefits and the
satisfactions of that
when people talk about somebody
completing them
it kind of it does make a lot of sense
when you think about that it does feel
like
and also the stories about being fallen
creatures
about there being a part of us which is
missing which is fallen which is
sort of permanently cursed to spend its
time trying to fix that which it can't
there is something embedded in our
experience
that does feel a little bit like this
it's a hole that requires filling
something that needs fixing something
that if only we could get it in there
this really interesting line from robert
wright's book uh why buddhism is true
where he says that the original uh
reading of life is suffering by the
buddha um the original word for
suffering dukkha
yeah is the translations contested and
some people say that it should be
unsatisfactoriness yeah life is
unsatisfactoriness and when you look at
life through that lens you realize that
the holiday you've planned for the last
year to go on when you finally arrived
there there's a bit of sand between your
feet and the sun's a little bit bright
in your eyes and oh i should have got
this blended instead of on ice and maybe
if i've got the you know the shrimp
instead of the chicken
that that is baked into our existence
and i think that the way that you
interpret that some people laugh it off
some people would complain about it and
some people might see that as
an innate sense that there is
there is something wrong
like existentially that melancholic sort
of feeling would come up this is the way
that life always is i go away on a
holiday and i just i i can't seem to
find quite the
sensation that i want and i think a lot
of the battle against that
is due to the fact that you can't
concede that that's a feature not a bug
of life that look like this this is
built into the fabric of our existence
yeah no i love that though what i would
say is that the melon to me the
melancholic response to
that being the nature of existence is
not to kind of like rail against it and
say oh my gosh you know the the bug
shouldn't be flying around right now no
flies at the picnic that should never be
um and instead to say oh yeah
this this is how it is right here um you
know in this non-eaten world this is the
way it is and and and further like this
is the way it is for everyone so there's
a sense in which
i think there's a great love that comes
from it like the fact that we're all
in this great sense of
dukkha or dissatisfaction or whatever we
want to call it um
there's a great
there's a great communion in that sen in
in that place if we can recognize it as
such
in your work on introverts you were
talking about how people
ape the beliefs of the those that are
around them in a little bit of a way
they sort of play the role that
introverts sometimes can
be made to feel like
that's not perhaps the role that is
optimal for them to play when they go
out into the world that they should kind
of act more like extroverts if they want
to get ahead and that can sometimes
cause people to not fully embrace who
they are
do you think that there's an equivalent
here with the sort of melancholy as well
that definitely to me feels like a
thread that's wrong between those two
pieces of work that you've got this sort
of hidden introversion people acting up
as extroverts and kind of this hidden
melancholy with people trying to hide
the fact that things affect them so
deeply oh yeah absolutely and i know it
i mean i knew it before but
gosh if i didn't if i didn't know it
before you'd know it from the letters
that i'm getting now um from all the
people who are talking about the extent
to which they hide it even from
themselves you know because i think
people are meant are made to feel that
um
that that aspect of themselves is the
one that could lead them to depression
or the one that's going to lead them
away from worldly success or whatever it
is
as opposed to learning to integrate it
into who they are and
really go deep with it
in a productive way like i i got one
letter
um from a filmmaker
who told me that all his life
he had had this exact reaction to sad
music um he used to live in new york
city and he would go to a party at night
and then walk home along the length of
manhattan listening to his music and his
headphones and he said he would be
overcome by what he
came to call
quote that holy feeling
and i love that it was like that holy
feeling but he said over time he kind of
learned to
to mistrust that feeling and to sort of
put a lid on it because of all these
social signals that he was getting
um but
he he was now starting to let it kind of
come up for him
and uh i think there's a great wholeness
that comes from doing that
there was a guy on the show a couple of
weeks ago called tom van der linden he
runs a store a channel called like
stories of old if anyone went and
watched some of his videos which they
definitely should it's great
he is so bleak with his video i mean
they're beautiful but
[ __ ] me they're bleak and the the
they're always
he uses dead space a lot in terms of the
music and the soundscaping that he puts
in there and he's talking about the myth
of masculine purpose or why we can't be
heroes anymore he's doing analyses
usually of of media and i wondered why i
what drew myself to his work and it
really is
there's something so melancholic and and
bleak about about what he puts out and
it speaks to something in me and it
it makes me feel like
well maybe other people
have this sense as well that that things
are kind of
a bit
a bit sad and a bit serious and a bit
lonely but a bit beautiful and a bit
sort of transcendent as well and it is
this this big melting pot
one of the things that keeps coming up
when i'm thinking about this is
the courage and the bravery that you
need as somebody to actually
embrace this first off to not be able to
hide it from yourself and then secondly
to put that out into the world right
whether you've got a youtube channel or
not you know even if it's just speaking
to your kids or your friends or the
person on the street or whatever um
i wonder why
people shy away from doing that i mean i
have
34 years of examples myself but my point
being that
i wonder why it is that something that
makes i love tom's work right it really
connects with me
and yet i still see in myself and the
people around me a
lack of commitment or a lack of courage
or a lack of desire to be sufficiently
brave to completely open up that
area of ourselves to others even though
we know that we appreciate it when
others do it for us yeah
yeah i i i have a
excuse me a theory as to why
we shy away from doing it and
i believe it's because
especially over the 19th century as
things
as we became more and more organized
around being a business culture
there was more and more a focus on
were you succeeding or were you failing
at business and then if you were a
success or failure was it because people
literally started to ask this question
explicitly they would say
is it because of good or bad luck or is
it because of something inside you
and increasingly people started
answering the question by saying it's
something inside the person
and they started like
and they started categorizing people
into winners or losers and this word
loser literally like the usage of it has
gone up astronomically over the 20th
century now into the 21st um even
in in the great depression there were
like newspaper headlines that would say
like loser commits suicide in the street
after like losing their money um
okay
so the more you're dividing people into
winners and losers of course no one
wants to be on the loser side of the
ledger
and so what you end up doing is
divorcing yourself from any of the
emotions or affects or
experiences that have anything to do
with loss you know you just don't want
to
admit to that
so i mean
so just the way it's such a false
dichotomy to say this person's a winner
and this is a loser as opposed to saying
we all win and we all lose the same
thing is true with the emotions that are
associated with those states
um
those all of those emotions belong to
all of us and that's like being a really
truly whole self
but
but in a culture of winners and losers
we don't feel like we can be do you know
alan
piece about this where he talks about
lady fortuna
oh gosh well first of all i love him i
am a huge fan of linda bouton and i
don't know about the piece but i've
heard him talk about how
uh
i think he refers to it as cruel that we
no longer
think in terms of lady fortune yeah
well that's exactly yeah he uses the
exact example the word of losers that in
the past in ancient greece they would be
called the unfortunates that lady
fortuna hadn't blessed them right
literally the people on the street the
the disabled the lame you know the
people that weren't able to work or
whatever they were the unfortunate lady
fortuna and the whole point of this and
that's i'm alright is lady fortuna
represented as the person that has
scales i think so yeah i think that's
right sort of balancing scales not fish
scales and yes
the whole point of that was that she
giveth and she taketh away
and i can't remember
whether it was epictetus when he got his
legs broken and they didn't heal
correctly
i feel like he'd been a successful
trader for a long time
and it had wealth or maybe it was
somebody else maybe it was the guy that
was the adviser to nero and
i think it was the guy that was an
adviser to you know he gets thrown away
in a jail cell and people are saying to
him this is an injustice this is
terrible uh well how are your family
going to exist without you and he says
well i've lived a pretty good life you
know lady fortunate she gave and it's
now her time to take away right and the
changing of that language to
any meritocracy where if the people that
win are worthy of their successes what
does that mean the people who lose are
worthy of what means that they're worthy
of their losses yeah
and you're right it puts
very much on people's shoulders this
degree of pressure and i can see how
anything that people fear would be a
precursor to something which would be
less optimal or less successful or cause
them to have less achievement which
would be widely socially
uh applauded they would
must not enjoy the bleak landscape must
not cry yeah
exactly exactly
i mean we we would literally train
children this way like in the states you
know there was the boy scouts and
children were trained you should be
cheerful all the time you should be
whistling you know being being putting
on a cheerful face will give you courage
it'll give courage to other people um
that
psychologist william james
started to observe that like it was
becoming
in the late 19th century it became bad
for him to even complain about bad
weather like you couldn't even notice
that it was cloudy outside because to do
that would be to be too down you know to
too much
on the negative emotion side of the
fence
so i this is a fear and a distaste that
we have inherited for a long time now is
this what you mean when you talk about
the tyranny of positivity
yeah very much so absolutely um
and it
we absorb the tyranny of positivity in
so many different ways so i tell the
story in the book of my dear friend
susan david um who is a writer and
psychologist who talks a lot about
emotional agility
she's a very cheerful person by nature
that's her temperament
when she was 14 her father died of
cancer
and
because she's so cheerful by nature and
because she had all these social
expectations she walked around for the
whole next year
pretending that she was okay like she
went to school literally the day her
father died she was back at school
acting okay
and for her it all started coming out
through bulimia she was like secretly
you know throwing up her chocolate chip
cookies in private
um
and it would have gone on that way
until the day that her english
literature teacher passed out blank
notebooks to the class
and looked susan in the eyes and told
her
write the truth of what you're feeling
just write it all down and she said i
the teacher i'm going to look at it i
might make a little comment or two but
this is yours to write your truth
and she was looking straight in her eyes
when she said it and susan started
finally writing which she really
felt
and she refers to that as a revolution
in a notebook um and you know and it led
to
a lifelong passion for helping people
to just make peace with all the
different emotions that we have as
humans
do you think there's something going on
here culturally is it culturally novel
to have such a
obsession with positivity and wanting
everything to be okay
is it something outside of just the
success of the individual is there
something else going on here
well there's definitely a cultural
aspect to it um and in fact
psychologists have compared different
cultures to measure how much do they
smile or not smile you know and you'll
be shocked to know in the us they smile
way more than in many other cultures um
but there are cultures in which smiling
is seen as being
um kind of suspect you know like why
would you be smiling so much all the
time it's seen as a sign of somewhere
between foolishness like as if you don't
understand how serious life is or just a
sign that you're not to be trusted
because clearly you're not telling the
truth
yeah because we need to be very very
cautious around them exactly
yeah i i it is interesting especially
coming from
the uk to america so we're kind of right
uh genetically perennially
a little bit miserable right that's why
satire and sort of that stiff epilep
thing comes from the uk i think it's
very very heavily born out of the
weather the fact that we're water locked
on all sides uh the fact that we've got
a long history
spitting sawdust salt of the earth
people you know coal mining and working
class towns and stuff like that and um
coming over here is very interesting to
see people imagine that um
relationship to the difficult
and
the kind of encouragement that i get the
kind of feedback that i get when i tell
different friends about things that i've
got that are coming up it it
the if it wasn't for the fact that it
was in the same language it would feel
like an incredibly different culture and
perhaps it is perhaps the fact that it
is in the same language makes me think
that the cultures are less different
than they actually are that's that's
probably exactly what's happening i've
had that thought too when i go over to
the uk
how do you find it
well i mean it's interesting what you're
talking about like i think with the uk
there isn't the same emphasis on uh a
kind of manic smileyness that we have
here
but i do think there's the same
or maybe a greater discomfort with
negative emotions or with talking about
them like you're not supposed to talk
about that right you're you're more
supposed to
show a stiff upper lip and a kind of
resolve and
and a kind of ironic detachment from all
of that
you're never supposed to be earnest i
think
that's very very true
that's very very the earnestness
if you can get it across in a
sort of side-eye
critical
way this is kind of like the tenor that
i notice on twitter a lot no one
actually ever points at somebody and
says that was out of order you're not
you you're not allowed to say that
that's something which it's always
everybody's reply back and forth when
they're having a disagreement on twitter
is some witty
this doesn't affect me quip
that's trying to sort of
smartly dunk on the other person's idea
it's never actually somebody breaking
the fourth wall a little bit and going
yo that's out of order you don't you're
not allowed to say that even if you're
on the internet and
i i think that that definitely gets
drawn across into the uk it's like a a
real
sort of
strange malignant version of the stiff
upper lip thing it's not quite what it
is twitter you mean yeah but also in the
uk as well you know there's just there
is a little bit of uh
a little bit of a difference in the way
that people
show their emotions i had i got to tell
you this story so it was the lunar
eclipse couple of last night last week i
think uh middle of last week
and the south of america especially
texas is one of the best places on the
planet to see it so i'm sat out on the
balcony there someone texted me and said
yo you're watching this lunar eclipse
and i was like [ __ ] i love the moon my
mom loves the moon mum's a reiki master
she has been for 20 years and she's
always been into stuff to do with the
moon yeah i need to go outside and look
at it so go outside did you look did you
see any of the images of this i didn't
so
it's like a
fiery orb in the sky the whole thing is
a red hue kind of like rust if rust was
lit from behind it's a very bright sort
of rust color
and there's different stages that it
goes through and i was i managed to go
outside while it was in it's full
and i'm sat outside and i started having
to breathe heavily are you going what's
what is going on here i was just sat
there silence no one else around there's
a pool below in the courtyard where i'm
staying
i was starting to breathe heavily and
then was
realized i was like i'm weeping
what am i weeping at
i was looking up and i felt so stupid
like what a what a [ __ ] thing to do
what a stupid thing to do to the moon
you've seen it
to the moon it's the moon not even lit
right it's the moon with us in the way
of the sun
between it okay okay
whatever i'll calm down i'll chill out a
little bit in this big pink sky orb and
taking some photos and sending them to
my mum and stuff and then uh i can't
remember what it's called it's not the
apogee it's something else so as
there's different stages to the eclipse
and as the earth begins to move out of
the way
parts of the sun start to strike one
corner so you can imagine that you have
this sort of reverse crescent that
starts to come in and it starts to get
brighter from the bottom corner all the
way up
and there's this still the same color at
the top and then this sort of line this
razor thin line of super bright yellow
light at the bottom and i just started
bawling crying i was like what is going
on like how can i stop this from
happening and i remember looking up at
it and going
really sort of questioning myself like
is this something that i should be
ashamed of like should i and i felt
shame i was like why am i as a man of 34
years old who's supposed to reach his
millions of people on a podcast every
month what am i doing crying at the moon
like some sort of really sad werewolf
what am i doing
crying at the moon and it was like tears
streaming down my face i was having to
scrunch my face up to try and like the
way that you do when you would sob
and then i'd afterwards when i look back
on it it's a memory that i really really
sort of revere and and love but at the
time there was a lot of shame i felt a
lot of shame come up around the fact
that i was this guy
weeping on my own
so was the shame because i don't i'm not
sure if you were watching with a friend
who could see you crying it was just you
yep okay
so it was just an internal shame yeah
and what do you think the tiers were
i've tried to work it out i think beauty
i think it was
just so awe-inspiring and it was huge
it's
a blood moon so that was one of the
reasons it was extra red it was this i
think it's called this the spring flower
moon as well because it's the
final oh it's the full moon of may which
is the last one before we get the most
flowers and something else and it like
it was all of the words together it was
a full sentence to describe this thing
and it just looked spectacular and i
don't think i was ready for it either i
think that was a big part of it that i'd
gone from working on a laptop to oh
there's a eclipse going on outside when
outside you just hit me in the face and
it was silent and beautiful i don't know
what it was but it happened and
yeah it made me think especially having
reading your book at the same time it's
like yo this is a
bittersweet emotion that i'm feeling
it's something kind of awe and dread and
joy and sorrow and longing all kind of
thrown together in this visual
representation that
seems to be making my face leak
i'm curious if if this feels like an
explanation to you because um
there was
there's this one passage that i came
across and it was very soon before
the book went to print
and i felt it was so great i actually
made it into a second epigraph because i
just wanted to highlight it so much so
i'm gonna read it to you and you can
tell me if you think this is kind of
what it was um so this is from
a
professor in the psychology of religion
and he says gregory the great spoke
about
what he called the holy pain which is
the grief somebody feels when faced with
that which is most beautiful
the bittersweet experience stems from
human homelessness in an imperfect world
human consciousness of and at the same
time a desire for perfection
the inner spiritual void becomes
painfully real when faced with beauty
and there between the lost and the
desired the holy tears are formed
i think it was holy tears for you that's
what i think and i'm telling you i'm
saying this as a total agnostic but um
or maybe not i don't know
yeah it's a it's a it's a strange one it
was really uh it really was something
else and uh
yeah this shame the shame is one of the
most interesting parts of it actually
thinking about why is it that i feel
like i shouldn't
feel something what is it that's in me
that's making me feel like
emotions shouldn't come out at something
so stupid or or also natural or so far
away from me um but yeah there's i think
there's something about
being a finite creature surrounded by
infinite complexity and then when you
see a representation of that it reminds
you maybe that the things that you're
probably focusing on
aren't that big of a deal there's
definitely a sort of a delta that you
feel between
the majesty and the beauty and the
grandness and the vastness of everything
and then the the smallness that you have
definitely made me feel quite small in a
beautiful way again yeah yeah but uh
yeah the uh the psychoanalyzing of that
i've spent so much time over the last
couple of weeks trying to work it out
and um
it was very timely that your book came
out so that wow
i mean
was there was it pure shame or was there
also a sense of wow this was like an
amazing moment that just happened to me
so was those two things combined oh for
sure i mean the shame on you sort of
came a little bit after it was
overwhelming mostly but given the fact
that
we've got this sort of tyranny of
positivity that you're talking about
especially in things like the workplace
how should someone
uh integrate their bittersweet emotions
when the world is expecting
the bubbly positive
susan that doesn't like bleak landscapes
like how how are people supposed to
navigate that space effectively do you
think
well i mean there's a bunch of things
there's clearly the
the
creating the spaces to just dive
wholeheartedly into
you know into these states of melancholy
and longing but before you even get
there there's something about just
engaging with beauty for its own sake um
because beauty
beauty will take you everywhere right
it'll take you to states of just joy and
bliss but it'll also take you to those
states of
melancholy and self-transcendence that
you were that you found with the moon
so
i believe we need to be integrating
pro-active encounters with beauty into
our everyday life lives and
preferably starting our days that way
um you know so
it could be for one person
listening to music or like
what or going out into nature first
thing in the morning whatever it is like
for me during all the time that i was
writing this book
i started following all these art
accounts on twitter and i would begin
every morning by picking a favorite
piece of art and then sharing it on my
social channels and it was it was such
an amazing experience because first of
all i was like really attuned to the art
because i was going through this
process and practice but also
it was then connected with a whole
community of people
who valued that kind of thing in the
same way that i did and it was such a
grounding way especially to start a
creative day of writing but really to
start any kind of day
so that's one thing i would say
what about when it comes to dealing with
other people
you know somebody asks how are you doing
and there's a response that you're
expected to give and it's not always
appropriate to say well do you know what
it is my dog died last night and i cried
at the moon and
a bunch of other things happened but
what we said earlier on is that there's
sort of this
role model bravery courage
thing
going forward that sets a standard for
other people to feel more comfortable in
this space and if as i guess that you
wanted with the introvert book
to hopefully forge a path for
introversion to be
uh more effective and more accepted
publicly
what about
bittersweet emotions how can those be
sort of integrated socially or in the
workplace better yeah absolutely it is
the same thing here and and it does help
when it comes as always as with anything
it helps when it comes from leadership
or from admired people to just be to to
just find moments to share something
that's a little bit
truer about the complexities of your
life and it doesn't mean you have to
like show up at work and
divulge
[Music]
whatever private private
most athletes fit foot that you're
dealing with at the moment or whatever
yeah yeah or whatever it is whatever it
is but but there usually are
moments for those kinds of openings um
you know at google there was that famous
study called project aristotle where
they looked at the
the top performing teams in the company
and tried to figure out what set them
apart from the others and they looked at
all the usual metrics like years of
experience and education and that kind
of thing but it turned out that the
factor that mattered more than any other
was the ability to communicate openly
about whatever
with one's teammates you know to to
really kind of show up in a full way
and um
you know and and gave the example of a
of a team leader who opened up to his
team about how he had been struggling
with stage four cancer which no one had
known about but when he did decide
to share that information it really
brought the team together and then other
people started showing up with their own
struggles
so each one of those small actions can
have a real cascading effect and i think
one thing that we can be doing is
creating spaces for people to do that
even anonymously you know at the start
of a zoom chat just to be inviting
people to
to share what they're truly feeling um
again with the option to not have your
name attached to it but
like you know the zoom chats were
where the organizer will come in and ask
how is everybody feeling today and you
know everybody's pumped and everybody's
thrilled and everybody's psyched to be
here and so they say and that's not
really true so what if a few people went
first and just talked about like gave a
more complex answer
it would open things right up
i think that
there's a resistance that a lot of
people will feel and i i i can feel it
in myself about about that opening up
thing that there's a sense where
this isn't the place to bring my
problems in that um maybe you can fake
it until you make it maybe you can lead
with actions and thoughts will follow in
a way that if you sort of act in a
positive manner that everything else is
going to come from that
but
i also think that
there's only so far that you can go away
from the emotions that you're feeling
until they're basically you're you're
just playing a role no it's just a
persona this isn't you
this isn't you putting a spin on what it
is that you're feeling it's you creating
something completely separate and
the way that you go forward into the
workplace for the most part
i don't think that's going to paper over
the things that you feel if you've got
some sort of
bittersweet emotions going on or if
you're dealing with grief or whatever
privacy would be something that i could
see as a reason why people just simply
don't want to have the questions asked
that to me makes a lot of sense but if
it's you thinking that this is actually
a road to rehabilitation and that you do
want to connect with people but just not
here but just not in this situation i'm
not convinced that that's true when i
think about the friends that i have the
best relationships with they're the ones
that have been
the most vulnerable you know what is it
that they say about a friendship um
true friendship is telling somebody
something that in the wrong hands could
be ruinous to your reputation oh that's
such a great way of putting that
yes that's exactly right
that's exactly right yeah and i listen i
there's a part of me that's really
sympathetic to all the objections that
you just raised um you know i used to be
a corporate lawyer before i became a
writer and i remember very distinctly
during those years it was like
i was going through something at home
let's say
you know you feel like oh my gosh i
don't feel like going to work today you
get there you have to put a smile on
your face and then suddenly you actually
do feel better um at least in the moment
you feel better but then there's the
long-term thing of like there's a kind
of burnout that comes when
you're showing up day after day
not as your true self so i think it
works to some degree it works in the
short term there's a longer term
question there
and there's also the fact that
we put those faces on because we know
they're expected of us
but if we were showing up in a culture
where they were less expected
we would feel
in turn somewhat less of a privacy need
that way
i'm thinking of
i looked at an a bunch of different case
studies of companies
where they did this you know from oil
rigs in the gulf of mexico to a billing
department in michigan where leaders
created
cultures where it was just sort of
natural for people to show up and tell
each other about things and come to each
other's aid
and they created a culture where that
was normal
and that was productive
so
what we assumed to be an unchangeable
aspect
of how work must be conducted
is much much more uh amenable to change
than we think
when you're talking about grief and
sorrow and stuff like that obviously one
of the
topics that comes to first of mind is
death
how do you think that people should live
and deal with life knowing that both
them and everybody else that they care
about and love is going to be gone
yeah this is like the the big question
isn't it um there's so many different
answers you know and i i spent time in
the book um with people who are radical
life extension advocates who are
who where their response to this problem
is to say well that's not gonna happen
you know i'm gonna work on making sure
that that doesn't happen
um
but for those of us who think it
probably will happen at least in our
lifetimes
i have found it to be like
tremendously um
sustaining to
to really immerse in the idea of of
impermanence
you know there's a reason that so many
different um
religious sects and the stoic
philosophers have
engaged in one practice or another of
remembering that at any moment
they could die the next day they could
die that day
there's something about doing that that
really helps you to live
in a much more engaged way
in the moment but also to accept death a
little more easily when it comes and i
say this having just
whether the deaths of my father and my
brother during covid um
i don't know you know nothing takes away
from the sheer like
horror and nausea of that moment
when
when you lose somebody
and at this
so i'm not meaning to say that this is
like a
this is an antidote
but
it's a mind shift it's more of a mind
shift to really be immersed
in the awareness of impermanence you
know so the tibetan monks used to or
maybe still do i don't know in some
sects um they'd go to sleep at night
they would turn their water glass over
before they would go to sleep as a
reminder to themselves that they might
not wake up in the morning and they
might not need to drink the water so
i'll turn the glass over now
and
and ryan holiday talks about how
the great generals i'm forgetting which
ones this was but in ancient greek times
you know they would have some great
victory and they would be parading in
front of of
their cheering people and there would be
a guy whose job was to be stationed
behind them as they paraded whispering
in the general's ear saying you're only
you're immortal you're only mortal
you're only mortal
and whenever i remember to do that in my
life i truly do find myself living
differently you know i put my cell phone
down focus more on my kids focus more on
the trees outside all of it
yeah the impermanence thing is an
interesting one i had uh
david
very famous transhumanist had him on the
show
three in a bit years ago
and i found is this david sinclair maybe
no so he's also been on the show but not
him i think he would class himself as
longevity not yeah yeah this david this
david was uh you know full upload to the
clouds right right intravenous mdma for
the rest of time
levels of flourishing and pleasure
hereto unknown by humanity it was like
real real serious stuff yeah um what did
you find amongst that group then you've
gone and spent this time at this
transhumanist conference speaking to
people that want to extend life so that
death basically no l impermanence isn't
a concern what did you learn
from your time with them what did you
reflect on
oh gosh there were so many things um
well one thing was i i guess i i went
into that kind of
skeptical of their project and feeling
um
that it in some ways it was just
uh
an extreme symptom of our culture of
positivity like we're gonna be we're so
positive that we're not even gonna die
you know we can triumph over that too um
i ended up feeling really quite
sympathetic to their aims but
but also
it was fascinating to me the
how little interested they were in the
philosophical questions of things like
well does
does death give a meaning to life you
know does the fact that we're not here
for that long they they would say that's
all nonsense that's a story that we tell
ourselves because we feel we have no
choice
yeah it's a cope it's a coke but as soon
as we think we have a choice then we
don't have to go there anymore
um
[Music]
what was also really interesting about
them was
so i noticed that so many of
the scientists who would get up and make
their presentations would begin by
telling a story of
someone beloved who they had lost you
know or so often like they would begin
with an image of somebody
bent weeping over
over a person they had just lost and it
was like
they were so focused on
on sorrow and longing and trying to turn
it into something else except the thing
that they were turning it into
was this rat this hope this promise of
radical life extension so it was very
interesting
um
i don't know one of them uh
one of them gave me the thought
experiment well actually before i tell
you the thought experiment i'm curious
like where do you stand
on the project
so i think that
transhumanism generally is interesting
which it definitely is and i think that
where the line between what david
sinclair does
and the other david the transhumanist
does actually begins to get blurred a
little bit i asked david when i sat down
with him look could you conceive of a
world where humans lived for a thousand
years with the bodies that they've got
and with different types of
regenerative
um uh treatments he said yes you go okay
well i mean
what's the difference between those two
i think some interesting things having
thought about this for a long time some
interesting elements are
um if you have a life which is a
thousand years or ten thousand years
long
i think that you um
tend toward a type of culture which is
insanely risk-averse
because if you're 40 years old and you
die you've only lost 40 years if you're
40 years old in the future and you die
you've lost 960 years yes so the way
that we view how
life should be spent the risks
associated with the things that we do i
think that that would change which is a
really interesting thing to think about
um i do think that it just copes on all
sides right this is people's inner
citadels that they're retreating to i
definitely do think that there's an
element of us saying that you know um
death and impermanence is an inbuilt
part of human life is a great way
to deal with
losing people and to say that it gives
life meaning is a really good way to
kind of just
ameliorate the fact that you're going to
go at some point in the future
i i don't know
i don't have a position on whether or
not if you live forever life would have
no meaning i'm not convinced
yet by the fact that death is what gives
life meaning that the lack of it at the
end is what's going to make it
purposeful uh during the existence
mainly because
i think that the type of mindset that we
have
isn't going to account for the fact that
we're going to live forever now if
you're a species that had always been
alive forever you might actually act in
a way that you didn't but the fact seems
that we've evolved not to live forever
yeah so human nature is going to going
to win out uh and you're going to exist
in the way that you do now but just
that line at the end of it is going to
continue going i
i can't see well if you woke up woke me
up tomorrow and said you're going to
live to be 10 000 years old i might
change some of the time horizons that i
think about doing things on but i
wouldn't stop doing stuff and i think
that's the implication that a lot of the
time is given for oh if we get rid of
death then life's not going to have any
meaning it's like well because you've
got an infinite amount of time to do
stuff you're just going to parkinson's
law your way through it's going to take
you three days to have breakfast because
it just doesn't matter there's no
urgency anymore i'm not convinced that
that's the that's the case um but i do i
mean it was is it ray kurzweil
that is
trying to
recreate his father and he wants to meet
his father in a virtual reality
an ai computer system i'm pretty sure
he's trying to do that uh that's
fascinating and or it might be max
tegmark it's one of the i'm pretty sure
it's one of the two
and you think
a lot of this just comes down to people
dealing with different ways of dealing
with grief and sorrow and impermanence
yeah i i think that too
and also that
i've never believed that um
that immortality is really the only
thing we're
deeply deeply longing for i i think as
well as that we're longing for
a world
of pure love um
a world in which there wouldn't be
strife there wouldn't be conflict there
wouldn't be
sorrow at all it's like it's not
it's just not true to say that
all the sorrow comes from
the fact that we're gonna die i mean
there's all kinds of sorrows that happen
along the way
and
at this conference that i went to there
was a kind of
there was an assumption that if death
could be cured then all the other stuff
could be cured too you know that war
could be cured and strife could be cured
and all of it could be cured um but i
think that there's a greater longing
when we talk about like the longing for
heaven let's say that's not only about
the wish to live forever it's the wish
for these
these more perfect states it's to get
rid of that duke in the now as well as
this is exactly exactly and i haven't
heard anybody talk
about that or to the extent they're
talking about it it's it's as a kind of
like afterthought
um that doesn't really make sense it
doesn't really add up when you look at
it
what was the thought experiment
oh the thought experiment was this was
meant for
people who were skeptical about the
whole project um you know people who
would say well i really don't want to
live forever and the thought experiment
is do you want to die tomorrow
what's your answer
no okay what about next week
no
what about the week after that
no
next year
ideally not 10 years no
50 years
no
so here so you keep going out like this
and it becomes almost impossible to say
that the day would come when you would
actually push the button happily like
assuming that you're healthy because
obviously once you become decrepit and
ill that's a whole different thing
but assuming health span assuming an
infinite health span it becomes really
difficult to imagine
you would ever you'd ever press that
button that's the thing to think about
especially given that a lot of the
foundation of this podcast was built on
sort of productivity and and optimizing
our daily daily routines and stuff
think about the fact that one day
you will have a to-do list that just
never gets completed
you know there will be things on that
list on that day
that forever are left undone by you i
feel like my to-do list looks like that
some of those things maybe stuff that's
on there now i don't know
uh
look susan kane ladies and gentlemen i
really appreciate this i really love the
work i like the fact that it's a subtle
dip into something that a lot of people
sense but kind of nobody's prepared to
stand and stare at head-on
so if people want to keep up to date
with the stuff that you do and see some
of your art postings where should they
go
yeah um best thing come to my website
which is susan kane.net and you can sign
up for my newsletter and then i'm also
on facebook linkedin twitter instagram
and the book bittersweet is
anywhere you usually buy your books
thank you susan i appreciate you thank
you so much it was wonderful to get to
know you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you